Kevin Milan for the major league
baseball Network joining us on behalf of
Bank of America well he'll tell you why
he's doing that but Kevin good morning
how are you Billy Patrick what's up
brother where are you right now I am in
san diego at careful san diego by the
way we land yesterday's was it july
eleventh intent or whatever it is then
and it's 74 degrees here in the grind of
the summertime why don't we all live
here what was your favorite city to go
into that you knew you were gonna get
into trouble Chicago vago is always a
fun one I love AT&T ballpark in San
Francisco but shy town you can always
find yourself some trouble on Michigan
Avenue get some starbucks it out there
grab a chair and then you've got great
scenery down there beautiful young men
and women walk in the streets daddy but
do you think that we should look at mark
Grace's career differently that he
played in played him he overcame Chicago
with all the distractions there the day
games and you go out after the game and
there was always friendship there for
him I'll makes it a great point what
grace should be in the Hall of Fame
first 10 batting gloves in April in
Chicago and yes hey games in Chicago
with the way he ran in Chicago so let's
put Mark Grace is one of the greatest
players in the history of baseball
speaking of the Cubs they coming back to
the rest of the the party here yeah it's
crazy Ike you know it's funny because
it's brought up obviously the way they
were playing they would have 140 games
we're all been like what and if Jake
Arrieta would have kept bitching the way
he had done at that 25 game streak we'd
all been like up here's a great picture
the world history of baseball so now
it's up to reality set in right there
starting rotation Lester and Arrieta and
lack Iran such a great streak uh they've
all struggled at the same time they're
still young offensive lead Annie I mean
no matter what you're gonna do when they
lost Dexter Fowler I think the leadoff
spot that hurts they got they got you
know you gotta move zobris up the
leadoff spot yet some young at-bats in
there their corners are guessing 30 home
runs an RBI for many years with Brian
rizal but just I just think they had to
go through this I was their father's day
weekend in Chicago a few
back they were 14 and 15 games up on the
Cardinals of pirates right now they're
seven and seven a half so we have a race
again at what point do you become you
know the difference between being a
buyer and a seller here and let's say
the two weeks after the ulster or is
that the window after the all-star break
two weeks yeah I think so the wild card
keeps everybody n use an example like
the Yankees you can see here and say oh
he's really in this thing there seven a
half games out right there 4444 are they
better than Baltimore Boston trial know
that I think they're gonna be better yes
but you know can you say that you're
gonna sell if you're Yankees you know
front office to the fans know but they
have Andrew Miller and they have a guy
like Chapman that everybody wants it'll
be very interesting to see how they get
against their first seven games and
they're playing Baltimore I think
Toronto I believe our Boston so closed
it'll be it might be yet might be seven
games for that pain Kevin Milan major
league baseball Network Analyst joining
us uh we talk about slam dunk contest
with basketball and you don't have the
stars in there does it matter if you
have stars in the home run derby or
should we put make a push to get trout
and Harper in there well I don't know
proper or you know who we have to have a
number it matters when you need the
power hitters I think this year we have
that Rumble got close to 30 home runs
you're gonna see Stan you got Cano a
three-time you know when ur that this is
what you need for the game you know not
taking thing aiming away but I loved by
those are more anybody but we had in the
Minnesota hometown kid awesome yeah he
can in a whole month but to me it was
like seeing come on home run derby um
saying yeah I get home our offense but
we want to see the 540 foothold on Jim
Thome it's dead center Sammy Sosa so
those are the guys you want I think we
have that this year you know and and and
I'm just that's the fun exciting time
for the fans that they want to see a
ball get really far not just over the
fence do you have any problem if the
baseball's are souped up for the home
run derby because it feels like
certainly McGwire at Fenway I i thought
i thought those balls were juiced up
yeah they're they're they're they're
basically hard about no problem at all
because that's what we're trying to
we're trying to entertain the fans right
you are sitting there grabbing a beard
and we want to watch LS he got things
break the freaking lights I'll see what
Chris Brian these guys at the ball I
greatly you know and they brought the
480 off the scoreboard where you go holy
cow so I've no problem well you also
have like Stanton I I ask Mattingly does
anybody does he remind him of anybody
and he said nobody's hit home runs like
Stanton has do you believe in yeah III
think that he's the closest thing to
McGuire because McGuire used to make the
visiting team stopped and watched apo
take bang press or we be in Florida and
we come off the field as 912 degrees and
we go right in the dugout and stop watch
McGwire take batting practice stands the
closest guy if not a tick above hit the
ball as far as McGwire didn't batting
practice the gloves for three swings he
put the triple deck you know pro an old
pro player Stadium Joe Robbie if you
want to call it but you couldn't never
Galarraga cook Kevin Brown up their
remember that slider the big cat went up
there and we're holding up the card but
why would take his first time in hit up
there it didn't make sense are you you'd
have to take five rounds and then maybe
take batting practice and third base to
hit up the third deck so scan has that
kind of power where you're like where he
hits the baseball it doesn't make sense
Benny and there's a there's a different
sound from certain guys there guys who
hit home runs and then there's that
sound sometimes it's somebody makes
where you can just hear the sound and
I'm sure pitchers do this and you is it
you know a player in the field they're
probably times we use went that's gone
that's crazy right in the scary you
might've thrown to him this did you
later thrown a ball gown away by
actually he just kind of he gets for a
little bit hits a ball Bob got you like
Obama picture I would tell stone listen
guy come on throw beat all middle and so
in the Hall of the Jewish girl but I
don't want Bob dog I know you got fake
teeth I don't why not Kevin joining us
part of a bank america with the MLB
memory bank if you would like to tell
the fans about that yes it's cool Bank
of America's connecting with baseball
fans around and you know shared level of
baseball by hashtagging to their social
media hashtagging MLB memory baking so
I'll see this what's your favorite
baseball memory and be going again with
your dad it could be something you did
on the field
think your loop stir with your little
basketball court there in the studio but
I seen your jump shot you're not gonna
play horse one day you're going down oh
well man you just can't just call my
doctor all right my memory is a Pete
Rose crashing into ray Fosse in
Riverfront Stadium oh yes all-star game
yeah [ __ ] I'm saying that was it right
yeah yeah and a nat ly Hammacher giving
up a grand slam and also a man Reggie
Reggie Jackson off the light tower
against doc Ellis look at you look at
you Fred Lynn taken at Lee hammer Kirk
brani right that what was that 1976 that
was lefty on Lefty there and Lynn hat
was what rookie of the year in MVP that
year I think yeah what you're [ __ ] six
I think 75 75 76 I think for Fred yeah
but I remember attlee hammacher served
up uh to Freddie that's the cool thing
bankamerica makes you slow down for a
second and thinking of your favorite
memory don't baseball memory and you
could hashtag it you know with the MLB
member big but I think it's a cool thing
cuz we all go back and go man I've never
sit in Dodger Stadium with listen Vince
Scully with my dad we're in the head
said that's the way used to watch the
baseball game you go there live and you
put Scully on the headset you know my
members here in Scully tell stories and
padraig ladies and Joanne had a
newspaper rounded we on when he was 13
years old on broke a window like you
know there's always a story they've been
told he's still telling them a Kevin
have fun in san diego stay out of
trouble goddamn thanks brother Ike Kevin
Lauren the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience